hey everybody michael here you know a
couple weeks ago i got to sit down with
tim poole i went to his bunker all the
way on the east coast
we sat down for the tim cast irl
and it was a fabulous fabulous
conversation you can go check out the
full episode that's episode 272.
i really really enjoyed it i loved
hanging out with ian and uh
sour patch lids and everybody on the
show uh but
i'm gonna give you a little clip right
here uh take a listen and then if you
wanna listen to the whole rest of the
show you you can do that
head on over to the tim cast irl episode
272.
when we read the news or we watch a news
story about something that we know about
we we can look at it and say hmm yeah
that doesn't sound right to me
uh no i actually know that's not true
now i actually have my own lion eyes
here you know and i knew that that was
not true
but then when we get to another story
where we don't i don't know iran or
something right so i'm not an expert on
we just take their word for it we the
thing we know about we know they're
lying to us but then the rest
who knows that's the gel man amnesia
effect yes have you heard the that's
so there's a guy who said he was gonna
name it after two smart people so it
sounds official
so i don't know i i don't know i
remember who actually coined the phrase
but
man it's it it rings true iran is a
really great example when i see cnn say
something like you know
hezbollah has done this i just go like i
guess yeah maybe
and then i watch them talk about the
riots of like peaceful protesters burned
down the city and i'm like
it must have been peaceful yeah am i yes
is hezbollah good
i don't know i don't know i don't i
don't think that's the case but who
knows what they're lying about you know
right yeah and so
especially when it comes to foreign
policy yeah we get into wars because of
it because the american people are just
i guess i just trust it and so that
that's kind of why
i think the easiest example of this is
true
the real political divide or one i
shouldn't say the real but this one of
the strongest is
do you actually pay attention to the
world worldly affairs because
you and i will disagree on politics but
we agree with happening with the world
which allows us to
you know applying a standard american
moral framework come to similar
conclusions on what shooter shouldn't be
yeah and there's also if you really want
to get woke to the political scene
one has to recognize there is a
difference between how the government is
supposed to work and how the government
works on paper
and how the government actually works
and the kind of real
ruling establishment and actually the
right wing is finally waking up to this
a little bit
when you know for 20 years the right
wing talked about how
there's the you know the public and the
private and the government and business
and you know public government bad
private business
good and yeah maybe this woke
multinational corporation is undermining
our entire country and culture but
but they're good they're good company
give money to company give tax cut to
company and government
even though the government is an
expression of our own political wills
through
through our elected representatives we
hope when it's working bad right
but now what is google is
google's a private company no we were by
squishy republicans we were told
google's a private company for a long
time
that doesn't seem that private to me
when when three billionaire oligarchs
control the flow of information in a
republic where speech is politics right
it's the same thing
the way we govern ourselves is we
persuade one another of things if three
companies are controlling that
that practically speaking is the
government you know i go back and forth
on this sometimes depending on the news
depending on
you know how it's it's hard to gauge
whether we are winning or losing and by
we i mean the people who believe in
individual rights free expression
and uh i guess i think we're classified
classic
i don't want to bring down everything
here by design well so you know there
was a funny comment earlier someone in
the chat said
they saw michael in the title and they
were hoping for malice but they got
nulls instead
real nice they're like okay real nice
guys but but you know michael mouse is
of the opinion that we're winning
yeah that uh and there's there's good
reasons to think so
like youtube just relaxed its rules on
uh community guidelines and monetization
some of them give people pause like
you're now allowed to show police
brutality videos and monetize them which
is
you know they think that's actually the
other direction it it popularizes the
myth
of police going on hunting microwaves
and things like that right but they also
have now opened it up to you know more
adult themed content to put it mildly
like news coverage
very serious you know issues swearing
even and so maybe that's a move in the
right direction
i wonder though if some of the
relaxation is just because
the election passed this is why the
election's over they're always really
nice to us
when it doesn't matter you know but when
it really does matter they
i mean i think we actually did see them
across the rubicon
during the shortly after the election
during the litigation
where some hipster rasputin
this guy with the nose ring in silicon
valley d platformed the duly elected
sitting president of the united states
regardless of which thing happened in
the election the guy's the president
and this oligarch took him out and he
could take him out and it wasn't just
him
they all worked in concert with one
another and i i
sort i mean this is actually a lot of
the topic of my my book my
second book but my first book with words
which is called speechless and
it's it's about this this problem of
free speech
what is it you know i think it gets back
to your point tim which is so right the
reason that i think we keep losing
ground
we lose grounded maybe they pat us on
the head and they're nice to us when it
doesn't matter but
we still keep losing is because we
are only thinking about ourselves we're
only thinking about this
individualist hyper-individualist
ideology we're only thinking about the
debate as one between
free speech and censorship when i don't
think it's i think it's a debate between
competing sets of standards
and it actually leads us into a trap
this i think conservatives fall for this
trap i think
the left understands free speech way
better than conservatives do
i think we kid ourselves when we pretend
that we understand it better
and the trap is this political
correctness
tries to destroy the old order that's
all it wants to do once all the old
rituals all the ultra it wants to get
rid of it
and conservatives react one of two ways
either this we go along with it that's
what the squishes do and they say oh who
cares oh it's
just a squid it's not a big deal
actually drag queen story hour is a
blessing of liberty
yeah whatever you know it's that kind of
thing and then but the second
way we respond which i think we we've
probably all fallen into this camp at
various times myself certainly included
is we'll say okay no i'm not going along
because i my free speech absolutist i'm
a
free expression whatever absolutist and
so
no one can ever tell me that this is
better than that or this is more true
than that
i'm going to be able to do whatever i
want and so you
disavow standards altogether either way
either way the radical leftists get what
they want